my turn yeah okay  let's be honest the trouble the trouble  all started when women were allowed to  vote  wow  hmm  you got it wrong you got it wrong i  didn't yes you did and that is because i  do think that there have been a lot of  problems with women being able to vote  absolutely but it started  a lot earlier than that it started with  a woman being deceived by the snake  that's where it started you know i was  gonna i was gonna say you've got to go  back to i don't know the 17th amendment  women voting is the 19th uh direct  election of senators 17th that was kind  of a problem you know there were but no  you go back  i go back all the way so i mean the  problem is still in some ways with women  yeah um  but yeah the 19th that's just a symptom  of original sin